what would you say is your process for
developing good novel ideas
you have to be aware that
clearly there are many other brilliant
people around
so
you have to ask yourself a question
why the given idea
let's say wasn't
tried by someone else
and in some sense it has to
do with
you know kind of simple it might sound
simple but like i'm thinking outside of
the box and what do i mean here
so for instance for a while
people in academia they assumed
that
you have a fixed data set
and then you optimize the algorithms
in order to get the best performance
and
that was so in great assumption
that no one thought about
training models on
anti-internet or like that that maybe
some people thought about it but if it
felt too too many as unfair
and in some sense that's almost like a
it's not my idea or so but that's an
example of breaking a typical assumption
so you want to be in the paradigm that
you are breaking a typical assumption
in the context of the ai community
getting to pick your data set as
cheating correct and in some sense so
that was a that was assumption that many
people had out there
and
then if you free yourself from
assumptions
then
they are
likely to achieve something that others
cannot do and in some sense if you are
trying to do exactly the same things as
others
it's very likely that you're gonna have
the same results yeah i
but there's also that kind of tension
which is uh
asking yourself the question why
haven't others done this
because um
i mean i get a lot of good ideas
but i think probably most of them suck
when they meet reality
so so actually i think the other big
piece
is
getting into habit of generating ideas
training your brain toward generating
ideas and not even
suspending judgment of the ideas
so in some sense i noticed myself that
even if i'm in the process of generating
ideas if i tell myself oh that was a bad
idea
then that actually interrupts the
process and i cannot generate more ideas
because i'm actually focused on the
negative part why it won't work yes
but
i created also environment in the way
that it's very easy for me to to store
new ideas so for instance next to my bed
i have a
voice recorder and it happens to me
often like i wake up in the during the
night and i have some idea in the past i
was
writing them down on my phone but that
means you know turning off this turning
on the screen and that wakes me up or
like a pulling a paper which requires uh
you know turning on the
uh light these days i just start
recording it
what do you think i don't know if you
know who jim keller is i know jim keller
he's a big proponent of thinking hard on
a problem right before sleep so that he
can sleep through it and solve it in his
sleep or like come up with radical stuff
in his sleep he was trying to get me to
do this so
it happened
from
my experience perspective it happened to
me many times during the high school
days when i was doing mathematics
that i had the solution to my problem as
i woke up
at the moment regarding thinking hard
about the given problem is
i'm trying to actually devote
substantial amount of time to think
about important problems not just before
the sleep
like i'm organizing amount of the huge
chunks of time such that i'm not
constantly working on the urgent
problems but i actually have time to
think about the important one so you do
it naturally but his idea is that you
kind of
prime your brain
to make sure that that's the focus you
know oftentimes people have other
worries in their life that's not
fundamentally deep problems like i don't
know
uh just stupid drama in your life and
even at work all that kind of stuff he
wants to kind of
pick the most important problem
that you're thinking about and go to bed
on that i think that's why i mean the
other thing that comes to my mind is
also i feel the most fresh in the
morning
so during the morning i try to work on
the most important things rather than
i'm just being pulled by urgent things
or checking email or so
what do you do with the because i've
been doing the voice recorder thing too
but
i end up recording so many messages it's
hard to organize
i have the same problem now i have heard
that uh google pixel is really good in
transcribing uh text and i might get a
google pixel just for the sake of
transcribing text yeah people listening
to this if you have a good voice
recorder suggestion that transcribe
please let me know but i it's some of it
is uh this has to do with the
uh open ai codecs too like some of it is
simply like the friction
i need uh
apps that remove that friction between
voice
and the organization of the resulting
transcripts and all that kind of stuff
but yes you're right absolutely like
during uh for me it's walking asleep too
but walking and running
especially running get a lot of thoughts
during running and there's there's no
good mechanism for recording thoughts so
one more thing that i do i have a
separate phone
uh which i
which has no apps and maybe it's like a
audible or let's say kindle no one has
this phone number this kind of my
meditation phone yeah and uh i try to
expand the amount of time that that's
the phone that i'm having i it has also
google maps if i need to go somewhere
and i also use this phone to write down
ideas
ah
that's really good idea
that's a really good idea often actually
what i end up doing is even sending a
message from that phone to the other
phone so that's actually my way of
recording messages or i just put them
into notes i love it
you